okay bb-8 wake up we're still three
months away from Star Wars The Force
awakens we've already seen this little
guy everywhere
you haven't met bb-8 but he's charmed us
his brief appearances and trailers and
on stage at Star Wars Celebration part
of that charm is mechanical
bb-8 has a 360-degree swiveling head
that's perched on a spinning ball of a
body that makes r2d2 a positively
arthritic now you can buy him as a robot
toy and control him with your voice like
you're a Jedi or at least a Jedi with a
smartphone app is that fun bb-8 last
year toy company Sphero was in the
inaugural class of the disney
accelerator program on the second day of
the program disney tapped them to
develop a bb-8 robot toy in time for the
new Star Wars film the company got
access to top-secret footage and set out
building the toilet with little more
than a visual idea of what it needed to
be Sphero had already made an app
controlled ball toy and turning it into
a robot with a spinning head presented
some serious design challenges Sphero
won't tell us exactly how it works but
there's a magnet in the head and in the
body to help keep them connected
obviously that requires some new
software and internals to deal with the
pendulum effects that came from the
hands extra weight in order to keep it
on well mostly obviously you don't need
to be an engineer to appreciate a
beeping spinning ball of Cuba Thatta -
all you do need is $150 back in the
fatal
okay fine we can do more stuff you and
do more stuff
all right let's do it